did you get yeah did you get offered uh
by the way did you get offered Princess
Bride was that an offer no I auditioned
you did yeah I auditioned for Rob Rob
Reiner and uh Bill Goldman how many
times William Goldman once once yeah did
you have the English accent oh yeah yeah
you poured it on oh yeah yeah just well
with a you know with a paintbrush and uh
uh a bucket and you know whatever I
could absolutely uh no it was actually
it was a fun audition because it was at
uh William Goldman's apartment on
Central Park West and I was on my way to
the audition and I remember I took a bus
up Uptown and I had the the New York
daily news I think it was and on the
back page was the the uh as always the
sports section I'm a big sports fan and
uh I was pissed off because the Knicks
had drafted a guy that I thought was a
disaster right right and so I'm holding
this paper and for some reason I knew
the scene I knew it you know I knew what
I was doing I felt confident and I
walked in and they both you know Rob is
such a he's just such a mensch yeah and
you know he came up and he shook my head
how you doing nice to meet you how how
how's it going I love you I love your
acting you know a wonderful career and
Bill Goldman who is a little shy
and I I said well I said to be honest
I'm in a really kind of bad mood because
the New York Knicks just drafted Kenny
Walker and Bill golden immediately
perked up because he's a huge Knicks fan
right and he and I started talking about
this trade
well I mean this draft choice and we
talked for maybe 15 minutes we were
going on and on about the Knicks and how
they'd [ __ ] things up and they'd say
that and that and finally Rob
interrupted us and he said excuse me uh
can I can I interrupt you guys do would
you mind reading Chris of course not and
I read the scene
and after I and after I finished not
after I finished just the sort of
penultimate line in the scene
Rob started laughing hilariously and
he's a great audience as one of his you
know great talents right and uh I after
it was over
I said he said that was that was perfect
that was just [ __ ] fabulous that was
just great and I realized that I played
the scene very seriously
because comedy is a serious business yes
you know yeah uh and and and the the
tone that I established in the scene was
just what he was looking for and that's
what did it so you didn't play it up at
all do you remember the scene do you
remember yeah yeah yeah it's where it's
where huberdink says to her I hope
you'll consider me as an alternative to
suicide because she talks about how
she's going Buttercup is gonna you know
throw herself off a parapet or something
I can't remember exactly what her line
was and and humperding looks at her very
sincerely because he can sell it this
guy
he knows how to sell it and he says
sincerely totally sincerely I I hope
you'll
consider me as an alternative to Suicide
you can't play that line
humorously just as you can't you know
I've got my country's 500th anniversary
to plan my my wife to murder a Gilder to
Frankfurt I'm swamped you can't say you
can't do that with you know you can't
consider what's the comic timing right
right you know you have to you have to
know what humperding is after at that at
that moment in his life was there a lot
of Direction during the movie did he
have direction for you or did you for
the most part were doing your own thing
I think that one of the things that Rob
does really well is he trusts casting
she trusts his actors he believes
strongly in
casting the right people
and um
and except for a few things
I would get some direction for Rob and I
would say okay and I would try it that
way and then he'd say okay now try it
your way
and sometimes he'd take my take and
sometimes he'd take his but that's you
know that's a joy to have that kind of
Direction you know that there's a moment
at the end of the movie where uh where
Wesley says that they're confronting
each other and and you know the audience
knows that Wesley is
severely compromised right and
Humperdinck is about to to engage him in
Sword Play and he's the world's greatest
swordsman except for of course Wesley
and and indigo and uh and and
Wesley says
uh humperding says to him something like
you know I know that you're compromised
I know that you're you you're not are
you bluffing
and he says
um drop that sword and he sticks his
sword out and humperding drops the sword
and goes and sits down right
the coward beneath the facade Right
comes out and just as a natural thing
because of the costume I took my I took
the tail of the costume and Tucks it
under me as I sat down
and Rob came over to me and thought
I think that's a little over the top can
you not do that this time and we did it
the other way and then he said let's do
it again and do it your way
and that's the take he kept really yeah
and it's it's funny but it's it's
situational funny right it's not you
know again one of these movies where
you're doing it you're like this is
special again did you feel that with
this one
we knew that the this was a great script
we all loved the script I've read the
book like 20 years before and I just
flipped over the book and we all knew
that it was a great script the casting
was just uh you know out of this world
uh
and Rob's take on it was obviously the
ripe exactly the right tone all the way
through you don't it's and it's the same
I mean it's actually similar in in uh
Fright Night in that you you have fun
with the genre but you don't make fun of
it right you don't look at the audience
in wink and say we're we're having fun
with this aren't we folks you play it
totally straight right that will kill it
the other way we'll kill it yeah